ah hi there
steve goffman here
i want to sort of update you on what
i've been doing with my arabic i sort of
started really into it yesterday i've
had looked at the alphabet before and
and i have to admit that the alphabet
sort of intimidated me because it's
cursive so
most of the letters are always
connecting
and the letters of course they go from
right to left which is not a major
problem but they have a different form
at the beginning at the middle at the
end and then stand alone so all of that
is is confusing and so i've been trying
to learn the uh the letters
but at the same time when i see a word i
don't
no longer know
what the letters are that were there and
and um
i was sort of looking for something that
would help me break down like which once
they're caught in the middle of the word
which letters are am i in fact looking
at so that was one issue because
again so i'm going to start learning
arabic i've been googling to get some
help there was a lot a long article
there by benny about how he suggests
just going you know based on phonetic
uh you know romanization first and then
going into the script i don't want to do
that because
i'm not going to be able to speak to so
many people here but i want to get to
where i can read and if i can read then
i can use links so that i can listen to
the audio and read the text
still i'm not entirely sure whether i'm
going to be doing egyptian arabic or
whatever kind of arabic modern standard
arabic i'm not too concerned about that
in other languages i can handle
different
pronunciation even you know portuguese
spanish a lot of the words are the same
it's not something that i worry about
right now
my main concern right now is to get to
where i can read
the
the alphabet when it's actually in
in script form
and i want to get some good content so
oh
i'll also say that i think i'm going to
start
um maintaining a sort of a diary
of my
arabic learning experience and i think
i'm going to write it up
on our forum at link so that other
people can participate with their own
experience of learning arabic i may also
talk about it a little bit at my blog
and of course i'm going to talk about
here at my youtube channel so i start
exploring
uh the first thing i discover is that
a lot of the content that we have at
link is not very good and that is the
sound quality the audio quality is not
very good audio quality is very very
important
so
we have uh
our
collaborator colleague in serbia zoran
and so i've asked him to go to upwork
which is an outsourcing website
and find people whom we will pay to
record high quality
uh
material such as our mini stories in
arabic so that we get a good quality of
sound i think that's extremely important
so that
as soon as we have that we'll be putting
it into our link library and people can
access it so then i went looking for
what was available on the internet
unfortunately a lot of the stuff that is
made available i looked up sort of easy
readers and things of that nature most
of the easy readers are children stories
i have zero interest in reading
children's stories and from my
experience children's stories contain a
lot of vocabulary that is not very
interesting to me and of course the
content is not very interesting to me
however i did find two
uh easy readers uh one is call and i'm
going to list these uh um on the forum
at link i think one i found them on
amazon again i googled something like
easyreader or amazon easyreader one is
called a first reader and the other is
an easyreader in arabic
one of them has audio
and
again this is what the way they do it is
quite clever the audio is available free
and you buy the pdf perfect i'm happy to
pay for a pdf which i can import into
link and i didn't pay for the audio but
they give you the audio you can download
it for free
uh so many of the systems that are sold
at amazon you have to buy a cd
in today's day and age if i want my
audio i don't want to wait for a cd to
arrive i just want to be able to
download it happy to pay for it so i do
have that in the background but the
problem is i still can't read because i
you know i've gone through the alphabet
many times now uh but i have trouble
sorting out the letters when they're
inside the word so i and i
i went and
either downloaded free or paid for a
number of apps on my iphone
ipad and i'm going to show you some
some shots of what i think is the best
one the problem and it's it's an
alphabet i found it in french alphabet
ahab i don't know what it's called
because when i look at it on my ipad it
doesn't give its name
uh but i'm going to show you some
screenshots of some of the things that
it does
it's very good it walks you through
all of the letters
it shows the different forms of the
letters
it then has a bunch of words that are
pronounced
and
and and then you know written
but even with all of that i still had
trouble i couldn't really see
how these letters were transformed
inside the word so then i discovered
something really useful it is the lexi
logos
arabic keyboard
and i'll put a little link in the
description box
and with that and i'll show you a
screenshot of what i'm doing and with
that i get my
you know on my ipad
i get the uh
you know
this is like an a lion
and it is
alif
assad so it's alif is the letter and
assad is presumably lion
and at first i couldn't figure out you
know you can't really see this with the
glare but i couldn't figure out how
what was inside that but by
you know trial and error on my lexi
logos key bat pad i was able to recreate
what i saw here and i do it for all the
different animals and so pretty soon i
had about seven or eight animals and
apples and whatever on here they even
give you a little google so you can
search
so i didn't know what that was for i
googled and all of a sudden i got some
scenes of
deserts and animals and stuff
not very relevant if i were to write
something in arabic that was relevant i
could google and and find stuff so my
strategy right now is to get to where i
can read and so i'm going to continue uh
using my um
you know my app here on my ipad
together with lexi logos writing things
uh mostly things words that i see so
that i can get a sense of how the
letters work
once i have a better sense of the of
this
then i'm going to listen to my easy
arabic stories
on link read them save them and
hopefully by that time i'll actually be
able to read the individual letters
within these words that i'm saving on
link and i'll be listening to these
stories
and by that time hopefully zoran will
have created well i've found someone
that we're going to pay to record and
and
create
some good content in arabic for link so
that i can move from my
easy arabic stories that i'm hopefully
starting to sort through at link move
into this
other content and i will gradually
continue doing that and at some point
i'll refer to
some grammar reference to
get some refinement on
on what i am listening and listening to
and reading so there you have it that's
the first report on my uh arabic
learning uh experience i should say that
i have no doubt in my mind that all of
the difficulties i have i will overcome
them
even now you know uh the alphabet is
much more familiar to me than it was and
as long as i keep putting in the time
uh you know using lexi logo's keyboard
listening to stories reading stories
eventually consulting some grammar
forgetting explanations if i just keep
at it eventually the brain will start to
get used to arabic
hi there i just want to add to my video
of yesterday this is already the next
day
i said that the audio quality of our
material in the link library wasn't very
good
i should correct that a little bit uh
the items that i went to which were the
items that i was familiar with in other
languages like who is she and these
other stories the audio quality wasn't
good
but by following on our feed where i'm
able to see what other people are
studying and what other people like
i found
a series a course that's actually very
good in terms of its audio quality and
it's called let's learn arabic and
there's another one called
conversations or easy arabic or
something i'd have to get my glasses on
here
and it's also uh has good step by step
it's called
so there are um and i'm gonna work on
this uh let's learn arabic it looks
really quite good
and we'll see how far that takes me we
are going to continue to produce
as i said
earlier in the video that we are going
to create more content with good audio
uh it's interesting too that
the other thing i'm going to share with
you my experience so one of the
difficulties i had initially was
you know as i use my lexi logos
typewriter to try and recreate the words
that i'm reading in these texts and of
course listening to them in text to
speech as kind of a hint as to how to
write them
that i have to i need to refer to a
table
where
all
four forms
of the arabic letter are available to me
because i i have to try and guess at
what the
what these letters are
it's surprising that the vast majority
of
you know tables that you can print from
the internet on
uh the
arabic
letters only give you the sort of
standalone standalone form and rarely do
the letters appear in the standalone
form so
fortunately i was able to find
a nice printable table with all the
forms and on our format link i'm going
to put up these links if any of you are
interested but i just wanted to add that
if you're looking for material at link
sometimes if you search in the library
you won't get stuff that's good if you
follow the feed and look at what other
people are studying you can sometimes
find better material
that's all i wanted to say
enjoy your any of you studying arabic i
look forward to hearing
from you
bye for now
[Music]
you